hallo mein name ist yukon herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge
teamleiter mir wurden unfassbar viele
kommentare geschrieben was ich hier
machen kann und es kam super cool bei
euch an dass ich mir gedacht habe bolts
millett ein bisschen up to date
tschuldigung bänke weil sie die letzte
folge ich gesehen hab dich fertig dass
die video hier da habe ich nehme ich mir
dieses neue update heruntergeladen das
ist gott semeta pay day mit jimi blue
ochsenknecht oder patches und ich habe
mir dieses mal wirklich mal eure tipps
durchgelesen weitsprung mit 5 dafür
jedenfalls hat irgendjemand geschrieben
dass ich diesen delfin hier unten nutzen
kann und mit dem wohl eine coole
fähigkeit habe das hört sich wirklich
wieder fährt
oder doch lieber damit seine flotte an
profil und es soll nämlich irgendwie
möglich sein dass ich wände hoch wieso
hat mit katze geschrieben es soll
möglich sein dass ich wenn der hof fahre
aber das hat ja gerade nicht getan als
ob er das kann ich kann sogar an der
decke fahren ich komme einfach überall
hoch wir werden mit diesem update hier
ganz ganz ganz ganz viel spaß haben und
ich bin wieder bei unseren altbewährten
freund dem tänzer im alter mit
kopfhörern auf hört sich das ganze noch
viel ekelhafter an ich schaue mal ob der
typ da unten das ganze überlebt hat hat
er wahrscheinlich ähnlich ich war oh
mein gott wie sechs notieren die nicht
wenn ich er drücke kann ich
da ist nicht wirklich wieder der tänzer
okay ich kann mich also hier auch
einfach hochfahren
was mache ich hier als ob dieser delfin
soviel verdammte scheiße machen kann ich
gewinnen übels was passiert wenn ich
jetzt ich kann nicht wirklich noch
fahren
nein ich bringe was sie so bin ich denn
je weiter runter delfin ich dachte schon
an der sonne wahrscheinlich andere leute
die da spielen so probleme das irgendwie
dass die demission nicht schaffen ich
habe das problem dass ich mit dem der
fiktionalen der sonne bin was geht alter
mich kann nichts aufhalten ich bin
einfach
er will die kamera vielleicht man
herangehen einem just the way you can t
help es sei denn es geht tatsächlich
überhaupt nicht klar man kann mit diesem
delfin echt gar nicht zocken passiert
wenn ich jetzt im wasser
kommen wir suchen macht flipper der
müsste ja eigentlich hier vorne genau da
vorne schwimmt herum der flamingo
reagiert irgendwie nicht im wasser ich
kann hier drücken was ich will und erst
im wasser tatsächlich wirklich einfach
unfähig dann nehmen wir einfach mal
fresse wieder mein gott hat der
eigentlich irgendeine fähigkeit ich
glaube was er denn fit ist auf jeden
fall gerade mal wieder schön in der
wildnis unterwegs ich weiß nicht will
mit dem delfin kann man coole sachen
mache mit dem was macht es da in diesem
spielen bis die ich gehe mit fred ganz
normalen die city ich habe ja wirklich
nichts gemacht aber das ist einfach
schreibt mir mal bitte in die kommentare
bekommt ihr lacht flash wenn ihr das
seht wenn ich das zocker oder denkt ihr
euch einfach nur nein bei mir ist es
irgendwie so ein mittelding ich weine
innerlich und äußerlich denke ich mir
auch nur so dem ich etwas das hier peter
von kag was ich spiele der komplette
straßenverkehr in diesem spiel wird
einfach nur ist einfach durch mit
durchgefahren boulder dieser stelle muss
sich einfach sagen dass videos vorbei